let's pause and take a look this morning  at the World Trade Center Memorial here  in New York City it's been 16 years  since terrorists killed nearly 3,000  people in attacks in New York Washington  DC and Pennsylvania ceremonies are being  held in all three locations to honor  victims of the September 11th terrorist  attacks a moment of silence will mark  the moment when the first hijacked plane  hit the North Tower of the World Trade  Center  at 8:46 a.m. Eastern Time  President Trump vice president pence and  their wives are leading the observation  at the White House next listen  [Music]  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  Gordon M Ameth jr. adalah Mero Abad  Marie Rose a BA Andrew Anthony abate and  there you see the reading of the names  they've done this every year since the  9/11 attack they will read every single  name this morning you're watching CBS  this morning will be really a princess  Richard and the Nieto Heinrich Bernard